und jetzt geht es hier weiter mit
der änderung des atomgesetzes ein
gesetzentwurf der cdu csu
der stirn bürger hat jetzt als erster
stellvertretender fraktionsvorsitzender
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen vor 207 tagen
hatte bundeskanzler nach dem russischen
angriff auf die ukraine die zeitenwende
verkündet
eine zeitenwende die in der
energiepolitik bislang nur unzureichend
angekommen ist verbraucher kommunen
unternehmen alle sparen energie wo es
nur geht die bundesregierung ist
weltweit unterwegs als bittsteller auf
der suche nach zusätzlicher energie aber
das naheliegende soll nicht getan werden
zu einer neubewertung der kernenergie
fehlen dieser bundesregierung wenn zum
spd und grüne geht offensichtlichste
wille wenn es um die fdp geht die kraft
sich in dieser bundesregierung
durchzusetzen
am 7 märz vor 198 tagen haben
wirtschafts und umweltministerium diesen
fehlenden willen schriftlich
dokumentiert es wurde uns ein so
genannter prüfvermerk vorgelegt mit dem
ergebnis dass die kernenergie bei der
bewältigung der energiekrise in
deutschland überhaupt keine rolle
spielen kann und soll in wahrheit war es
doch so meine damen und herren das war
kein prüfer merkt sondern eine wie sie
jetzt wissen in wenigen tagen schnell
zusammengestellte zusammenstellung aller
gegenargumente
das hätte wirklich jeder praktikant in
ihren ministerien genauso machen können
und seither ist viel zeit vergangen zu
viel zeit vergangen eine lange zeit die
nicht genutzt wurde um den weiterbetrieb
vorzubereiten eine lange zeit die nicht
genutzt wurde um neue brennstäbe zu
beschaffen sie haben nicht das
notwendige getan um uns vor drohender
strommangel arge und blackout in diesem
winter zu bewahren
stichwort stresstest ein halbes jahr
nach diesem so genannten prüfvermerk hat
minister habeck dann endlich sich ein
stück weit korrigiert das konzept der
einsatzreserve für lediglich zwei der
drei kernkraftwerke vorgeschlagen aber
auch heute ist dennoch so keiner weiß
wirklich was genau das sein soll wie das
technisch gehen soll ist völlig offen
die ernstzunehmenden bedenken der
betreiber werden von minister habe
einfach abgetan wird es alles rechtlich
geregelt werden soll ist auch völlig
offen das führt die nukleare sicherheit
zuständige ministerium von frau länder
zwischendurch erklärt die erforderlichen
änderungen seien im atomgesetz
vorzunehmen nun heißt es diese woche im
atomgesetz werden lediglich wenige
randbedingungen geregelt was denn nun
sie hatten monate zeit solche fragen zu
klären noch einmal sie haben zu viel
zeit verschwendet anstatt schlichtweg
ihre arbeit zu machen und uns auf alle
szenarien vorzubereiten
für diese bundesregierung ist lediglich
klar wann die einsatzreserve geregelt
werden soll nämlich auf jeden fall nach
dem neunten oktober nach der
landtagswahl in niedersachsen
was für ein durchschaubares politisches
spiel zulasten der
energieversorgungssicherheit zu lassen
einen klaren rechtlichen rahmen zu
lasten der stromkunden zu lasten der
glaubwürdigkeit von politik und
insbesondere auch zulasten der
glaubwürdigkeit von deutschland in
europa meine damen und herren
welches signal senden wir denn aus wenn
wir uns in der aktuellen krisensituation
den luxus leisten kapazitäten vom netz
zu nehmen gleichzeitig aber europäische
solidarität in energiefragen
einzufordern kohlestrom aus polen
atomstrom im winter dann aus frankreich
und gleichzeitig eigene kernkraftwerke
abschalten das ist doch wirklich absurd
meine damen und herren wir
schlagen ihnen heute konkret die
änderung des atomgesetzes vor denn das
atomgesetz ist das passende und seit
über 60 jahren bewährte immer weiter
fortentwickelt regelwerk wir schlagen
eine verlängerung des befristeten
betriebs der drei noch laufenden
kernkraftwerke um zwei jahre also wie
auch von der fdp als partei beschlossen
bis ende 2024 vor
kein ausstieg vom ausstieg sondern
befristeten weiternutzung solange es
schlichtweg notwendig ist es geht um ich
habe es ihnen gerade gesagt bis 2024
dann muss geprüft werden wie die
situation anders macht dann die
bundesregierung also wenn es so lange
durchhalten können sie es machen aber es
geht darum das notwendige zu tun und
nicht ihren ideologischen träumen
hinterher zu bringen
es geht um unzählige kilowattstunden
strom die uns sicherheit geben was
unsere versorgung anbelangt und die
natürlich auch zu sinkenden strompreisen
führen werden wir bekennen uns zum
massiven ausbau der erneuerbaren
energien die uns aber eben allein nicht
durch diesen und den kommenden winter
bringen werden meine damen und herren
insbesondere liebe abgeordneten der fdp
in genau 100 tagen ist samstag der 31 12
10 20 22h
erlischt die berechtigung zum
leistungsbetriebs der kernkraftwerke
isar 2 emsland und neckarwestheim 2
nämlich dann wenn diese bundesregierung
nur diskutiert anstatt zu handeln
deshalb rufe ich sie auf die
entscheidung ist überfällig tun sie das
in der energiekrise einzig vernünftige
nutzen sie alle optionen die deutschland
in dieser prekären lage zufügen hat
stimmen sie mit uns für die änderung des
atomgesetzes zu vorübergehenden
weiternutzung der drei kann
bis 2024 soviel steffen bilger ihr aus
der nächste redner ist jakob blankenburg
obmann im parlamentarischen beirat für
nachhaltige entwicklung er kommt von der
spd dieser beirat ist im parlament so
etwas wie er hat so etwas wie einem
wachen funktion es steht in den
beschreibungen es wird gewählt sobald
ein vorhaben die nationalen
nachhaltigkeitsstrategie außer acht
lässt mal sehen was
in den letzten wochen und monaten schon
intensiv für einen weiterbetrieb der
atomkraftwerke geworben hat da liegt uns
nun auch ein entsprechender
gesetzentwurf zur änderung des
atomgesetzes vor und die kolleginnen und
kollegen der union fordern darin einen
weiterbetrieb der drei noch am netz
befindlichen reaktoren isar 2
neckarwestheim 2 und emsland sollen bis
zu 20 24 weiterlaufen als argument
verweisen sie auf die sicherstellung der
stromversorgung
angesichts der unbestrittenen
angespannten versorgungssituation in
deutschland und in unseren europäischen
nachbarstaaten so weit so bekannt aber
was neu ist in diesem gesetzentwurf und
worüber auch sie eben gerade weniger
laut gesprochen haben das sind drei
punkte und die gehen wir jetzt mal
gemeinsam durch punkt eins und die
sicherheit der atomkraftwerke gespielt
für die union offenbar eine eher
untergeordnete rolle üblicherweise der
werden die atomkraftwerke alle zehn
jahre einer intensiven
sicherheitsüberprüfung unterzogen und
diese sicherheitsüberprüfungen die
wehren zuletzt 219 fällig gewesen wurden
dann aber ausgesetzt mit der bedingung
dass die atomkraftwerke ende diesen
jahres abgeschaltet werden die letzte
solche überprüfung die liegt also schon
13 jahre zurück eigentlich grund genug
die sicherheitsüberprüfungen bei einer
geplanten laufzeit laufzeitverlängerung
sofort anzugehen das zeigen auch die
aktuellen mängel wie das ventil lag am
akw isar 2
aber wer aber der gesetzentwurf der
union sieht stattdessen vor dass das
ergebnis einer sicherheitsüberprüfung
dass bis ende 20 23 vorgelegt werden
soll also in über einem jahr punkt zwei
die union spricht offiziell über einen
weiterbetrieb der atomkraftwerke bis 20
24 also zwei jahre länger als geplant
schauen wir aber in den gesetzentwurf
dann zeigt sich dass sich die union eine
hintertür für einen deutlich längeren
weiterbetrieb auf dem feld die
bundesregierung soll bis ende 2020 24
einen bericht vorlegen ob die
energieversorgungs krise anhält sollte
das der fall sein dann will die union
die atomkraftwerke noch länger laufen
lassen aber aber und jetzt da wird es
richtig interessant die union will die
entscheidung über einen weiterbetrieb
der atomkraftwerke nicht nur von der
energiesicherheit abhängig machen wie
wir eben gerade gehört haben sie will
sich auch zum einen die preisentwicklung
anschauen zum anderen aber auch die
einhaltung der klimaziele mit
einbeziehen und gerade das ist
bemerkenswert und das ist bemerkenswert
bleiben die energiepreise also hoch und
sehen wir in zwei jahren höhere co2
emissionen als erwartet dann hätte das
ein noch längeres weiter so bei der
atomkraft zur folge bravo liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen von der union
die eigenen versäumnisse beim ausbau der
erneuerbaren energien und beim
klimaschutz aus den letzten jahren
werden dann also zur begründung für die
weitere notwendigkeit der atomenergie
genutzt
und und das bringt mich dann auch direkt
zu punkt 3 dem märchen vom beitrag der
atomenergie zum klimaschutz dass die asd
fraktion dieses mädchen gern erzählt das
wissen wir bereits aber nun springt die
union sich offenbar auch auf diesen zug
mit auf sie verweisen in ihrem
gesetzentwurf explizit auf den wichtigen
beitrag des verlängerten betriebs der ak
w zur weiterverfolgung der nationalen
klimaziele aber dabei ist klar dass
atomenergie keineswegs co2 neutral ist
bei der stromproduktion selber ja da
darf man ruhig mal klatschen
bei der bei der stromproduktion selbst
da werden zwar kaum treibhausgase
freigesetzt vor und nach der
stromproduktion da ist das aber anders
und betrachtet man den gesamten
lebensweg der atomenergie vom uranabbau
da können sie auch gerne mal die
freundinnen und freunde in sachsen
fragen wie sie das bei der wismut damals
fanden bis hin zur endlagerung da ist
die klimabilanz von atomkraftwerken
verheerend von den gefahren des
radioaktiven atommülls ganz zu schweigen
geht es uns geht es uns also um klima
und umweltfreundliche energieerzeugung
der bleibt deshalb nur ein wirklich
nachhaltiger weg und das ist der ausbau
der erneuerbaren energie und da da liebe
union da müssen sie sich die frage
gefallen lassen ob sie unter dem
deckmantel der schon wieder auch keinen
atomdebatte mit ihrer verhinderung und
verzögerungs politik der letzten jahre
vor ort fahren wollen nicht umsonst
sieht der zweite stresstest der
übertragungsnetzbetreiber im schlimmsten
und ich wiederhole im schlimmsten
szenario nur im süden deutschlands das
risiko temporärer strommangel situation
hier wurde der ausbau der erneuerbaren
energien in den letzten jahren mit
instrumenten wieder 10h regel im bereich
windkraft systematisch verhindert
mit dem immer gleichen debatten über die
rückkehr zur atomenergie da verschwenden
wir wertvolle zeit auf dem weg zu einer
wahrlich kostengünstigen
umweltfreundlichen und emissionsarm
energieerzeugung zu einer
energieerzeugung auf basis von
erneuerbaren energie liebe kolleginnen
liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen der union
lassen sie uns gemeinsam die
rahmenbedingungen für erneuerbare
energien verbessern statt die atomkraft
wieder zu beleben dafür liegen genug
vorschläge auf dem tisch gemeinsam
können wir es anpacken vielen dank
jakob in blankenburg war dass der noch
einmal dargestellt hat dass der weg
weiter mit der atomkraft der falsche sei
die aus wurde erneuerbaren energien
bringt die lösung karsten hill sitzt für
die fdp fraktion
präsidentin meine damen und herren liebe
landsleute
afd wirkt die cdu bringt zweite fraktion
im deutschen bundestag einen
gesetzentwurf ein indem sie fordert die
drei noch am netz befindlichen
kernkraftwerke weiterlaufen zu lassen
inhaltliches gegen den gesetzentwurf
nicht viel einzuwenden allerdings ist ja
nicht notwendig da die afg fraktion
bereits eigenen entsprechenden
gesetzentwurf eingebracht hat dem sie
heute abend einfach zustimmen müssen es
stellt sich die frage hat die cd 100
zwischenzeit begriffen dass es ein
fataler fehler war aus der kernkraft aus
rein politischem kalkül auszusteigen
wurde sind es nur die umfragewerte nach
denen eine mehrheit der bevölkerung die
weiternutzung der kernkraft befürwortet
wenn frau merkel nicht ohne ein
vernünftiges argument den ausstieg
beschlossen hätte ständen kugelhaufen
reaktoren eine deutsche erfindung in
deutschland und nicht in china in
deutschland stände der erste test
flüssige brennstoff reaktor und nicht in
china eine diskussion über endlager gebe
es gar nicht mehr weil die feststoffe
der heutigen kernkraftwerke in flüssige
brennstoff reaktoren verarbeitet werden
wir wären weiterhin weltspitze kernkraft
und nicht ein land ein land mit der
dümmsten energiepolitik der welt das
potenzial der kernkraft ist nicht mal
ansatzweise ausgeschöpft die
eingeschränkten kognitiven fähigkeiten
der meisten auf der linken seite
verhindern dass sie dieses potenzial
erkennen neben ihnen sitzen
machtversessene opportunisten die den
grünen ideologen einfach nur folgen
davon gibt es bei der cdu auch einige
oder wie eine ehemalige
cdu-bundestagsabgeordnete sie nannte
linke und grüne spinner die aus ihrer
sicht die cdu seit merkels
machtübernahme geflutet haben aber es
gibt auch ausgesprochene kernkraft fans
und ich hoffe dass diese in der cdu bald
wieder das energiepolitische zepter
übernehmen im moment sind es eher die
die nur den wählerstimmen hinterher
hecheln und sich erst zur kernkraft
beginnen seit demoskopen herausgefunden
haben dass ich dafür eine mehrheit in
der bevölkerung findet im gegensatz zu
cdu steht die fdp seit ihrer gründung
zur kernkraft weil es die sauberste
effizienteste und platzsparend der
energiequelle ist wir haben dazu sich an
hier im bundestag eingebracht und wurden
dafür niedergeschrieben vor allem von
links aber auch von den ehemals
liberalen die sind in der zwischenzeit
wahrscheinlich aufgrund der rapide
zurückgehenden zustimmungswerte auch auf
den zug kernkraft aufgesprungen
übereinstimmend sagten herr lindner
unter der man müsse jetzt die
parteipolitischen spielchen lassen und
herr dürr ich zitiere es sei
verantwortungslos die letzten drei
kernkraftwerke abzuschalten kollegen sie
haben heute haben die möglichkeit ihren
worten auch taten folgen zu lassen
lassen sie die parteipolitische
spielchen seien sie nicht
verantwortungslos und stimmen sie heute
abend unserem gesetz zu tun sie es nicht
sind sie gelinde gesagt im höchsten maße
unglaubwürdig
ich bedanke mich für ihre aufmerksamkeit
die nächste rednerin in der debatte ist
julia verbinden von den bündnisgrünen
sich sie zuständige stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende
[Applaus]
präsidentin liebe kolleginnen hund zu
hörende ich kann es kurz machen
atomkraft ist unflexibel riskant und
teuer je länger die atomkraftwerke
laufen desto länger stehen sie auch der
energiewende im weg sie blockieren den
ausbau der erneuerbaren und zu diesem
fazit ist letzte woche auch das ifo
institut noch mal gekommen
da kein widerspruch erwähnt was läuft da
eigentlich in bayern das wird doch nach
einem sehr seltsamen gleichschritt von
ihrer tochter preussen elektra und der
staatskanzlei erst behauptet man das akw
isar 2 konnte ohne probleme noch viele
monate einfach so weiterlaufen sogar
herr merz hat sich das persönlich vor
ort überzeugt aber jetzt stellt sich
raus man hat vergessen zu erwähnen das
akw muss repariert werden
+ es scheint auch gar nicht mehr so viel
brennstoff vorhanden zu sein wie herr
söder uns weismachen wollte hat das
kraftfeld überhaupt noch genug kraft
nach der reparatur wieder hochzufahren
dafür dass die letzten akw s kurz vor
der rente sind produzieren sie von der
union reichlich viel heiße luft
tochter verlinken gestatten sie eine
zwischenfrage oder bemerkung aus der
cdu/csu
vielen dank frau kollegin dr verlinken
für die möglichkeit der zwischen frage
sind sie bereit zu akzeptieren und mir
zuzustimmen dass die situation bei dem
bayerischen kernkraftwerke insoweit
unproblematisch ist es noch nicht einmal
ein meldepflichtiger vorgang vorliegt
wenn ein ventil repariert werden muss
und sind sie bereit zu akzeptieren dass
das unnötig skandalisiert wird
lieber kollege
lieber kollege von der union wir machen
uns hier seit wochen seit monaten
gedanken darüber wie wir eine
energiesicherheit gewährleisten können
für deutschland und und wenn dann ein
betreiber sagt wir bieten euch an monate
lang können wir hier am netz bleiben wir
können zusätzlichen strom produzieren
und dann rauskommt bei intensiveren
gesprächen nie wir müssen noch mal
runterfahren wir müssen noch mal was
reparieren und dann ist die frage wann
können wir wieder hochfahren wie viel
brennstoff haben wir dann überhaupt noch
dann ist das keine verlässliche
kommunikation
wir brauchen wir transparenz wir
brauchen transparenz was tatsächlich der
zustand ist in diesen atomkraftwerken
sonst hat man keine vernünftige politik
machen sie wollen
lieben unser land mit einer debatte
beschäftigen die wenn überhaupt nur
einen wichtigen beitrag leisten könnte
aber sie haben doch aufgeplustert und
ihren fetisch von neuen brennstäben hat
fleht um davon abzulenken was in den
letzten jahren in einer unionsgeführten
bundesregierung energiepolitisch alles
falsch gelaufen ist anstatt ihre wähler
anstatt ihrer fehler herr merz endlich
mal zuzugeben oder aus der vergangenheit
wenigstens zu lernen kamen sie in der
mottenkiste und fordern ein revival der
technologie des letzten jahrtausends wie
ans ampel und insbesondere das
energieministerium und robert habeck
sind trendy four seven dabei echte
energie sicherheitspolitik in dieser
krise zu machen auf klimafreundliche
energie umzustellen und mit
umweltminister an steffi lemke das
kapitel der strom strom endlich
abzuschließen denn atomkraft ist nun
wirklich keine lösung für irgendeines
unsere probleme das einzige problem das
die atomkraft aus ihrer sicht
vermeintlich löst ist die fehlende
profilierung der union und ich muss
ihnen sagen das risiko das risiko ein
als es atomkraftwerke länger laufen zu
lassen finde ich deutlich bedrohlicher
ist das risiko dass die union nun mal
lieber gerade gar kein anderes thema hat
denn ihr gesetzentwurf heute derzeit
doch 1 sie haben als partei nie wirklich
hinter der erkenntnis ihrer ehemaligen
parteivorsitzenden gestanden frau merkel
hat als physikerin als physikerin und
als kanzlerin vor elf jahren zur
kenntnis nehmen müssen und so
formulierte sie das selbst sie
formulierte das so selbstzitat selbst in
einem hochtechnologieland wie japan sind
die risiken der kernenergie nicht sicher
beherrscht und sie wollen jetzt hier
einen gesellschaftlichen konsens zum
atomausstieg wieder aufschnüren denn all
diesen diesen konsens an alle fraktionen
diesen ausstieg an alle fraktionen im
bundestag damals beschlossen und zwar
mit sehr guten gründen wurde dieser
ausstieg beschlossen diese gründe sind
heute genauso richtig und aktuell wie
damals und wenn sie von der union in der
aktuellen situation wirklich wenn sie
wirklich einen beitrag leisten wollen
für energiesicherheit für unabhängigkeit
von energieimporten für stabile
energiepreise dann bringen sie den
ausbau der windkraft endlich in den
bundesländern voran wo sie mitregieren
allen voran in bayern danach danach
können wir weiterreden
julia verlinken also hier die
bündnisgrüne mit grüner politik pur auch
mit den begründungen und ich gebe noch
eine hinzu gehaben waldland das waren in
niedersachsen in einem monat das spielt
sicherlich auch eine rolle danach muss
dann noch mal neu geschaut werden woher
eigentlich die energie ab januar kommen
wird ralph linke jetzt für die linke
zittere ich bei nachrichten rund um die
ukrainischen atomkraftwerke
artillerie-beschuss zerstörte
stromleitungen und personalmangel beim
akw es aber russia schwören die akute
gefahr eines neuen tschernobyl eines
neuen fukushima herauf union und fdp die
französische energiepolitik
frankreich steht kurz vor dem blackout
im august standen von 60 gigawatt der
französischen akw nur 31 gigawatt zur
verfügung durchrosten kühlleitung die
getauscht werden müssen spannungsrisse
korrosion bei einem typ von
atomreaktoren ab zwang wären abschaltung
übrigens entdeckt bei den zehnjährigen
sicherheitskontrollen das ist die
realität die akw emsland neckarwestheim
und isa hätten spätestens 2019 diese
zehnjährigen kontrollen durchführen
müssen wegen der geplanten stilllegung
22 wurde darauf verzichtet
trotzdem glauben union fdp und auch die
deutschen akw wären sicher und könnten
problemlos weiter betrieben werden das
ist naiv und das ist falsch zu
glauben halte ich mich als techniker
lieber an fakten am 19 september teil
der preussen elektra mit dass im akw
isar 2 ein ventil act das wäre kein
problem bis zum 31.12 allerdings wäre
ein ventil wechsel bei einem längeren
betrieb des akw es notwendig sagt der
betreiber die wartung müsste spätestens
im oktober erfolgen weil die vorhandenen
brennstäbe fast ausgebrannt sind wegen
fehlender reaktivität könnte sonst das
akw nicht mehr in betrieb gehen sagt der
betreiber
das ist die realität die bestell zeit
für brennstäbe beträgt mindestens 18
monaten märz dann sind die zwei
kritischen winter vorbei die brennstäbe
bestehen auf rang
54 prozent des weltweiten fans werden in
kasachstan russland und usbekistan
gefördert im jahr 2020 verbraucht nur
die usa frankreich japan und südkorea 56
prozent des weltweit geförderten urans
ohne uran von putins gnaden wird es wohl
keinen neuen brennstäbe für deutsche akw
geben das ist die realität
liebe bürgerinnen und bürger
kennen sie den unterschied zwischen
einem atomkraftwerk und einem ddr pkw
trabant
beide stammen aus dem letzten
jahrtausend aber für den trabant gibt es
noch ersatzteile
die linke fordert die sofortige
aufhebung der decke bei solaren vor
allem bei bioenergie für ein größeres
stromangebot wir fordern eine änderung
der abgaben systematik damit stadtwerke
den windstrom für fernwärme nutzen
können statt dass die windräder bei
stark strom abgeschaltet werden das
sport gas für die gaskraftwerke bei
flaute wir fordern ein ende der
profitmaximierung von energiekonzern
verstaatlichen wir diese konzerne
wir brauchen ein preiswertes strom und
gas grund konsequentere bürgerinnen und
wirkung
und damit die abzocke an tankstellen
energie und an energiebörsen aufhört
fordert die linke ein preis deckel für
strom und gas
und auch damit die kleine mittlere
unternehmen finanziell überleben und
arbeitsplätze erhalten bleiben
damit bürgerinnen und bürger
systemrelevante dienstleistung und
unternehmen sicher versorgt werden
fordere ich von der bundesregierung eine
eindeutige belieferung zu rasche
kolleginnen und kollegen der union statt
über den weiterbetrieb der akw zu
fantasieren arbeiten sie lieber an
umsetzbare lösung vielen dank
nächste rednerin für die fdp-fraktion
judith skudelny
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen im juni dieses
jahres hat sich der wirtschaftsminister
an die menschen gewandt mit den worten
jede kilowattstunde hilft in dieser
situation
damit wurden die menschen dazu
aufgefordert ihren beitrag dazu zu
leisten mit der energie krise die durch
putins völkerrechtswidrigen
angriffskrieg auf die ukraine und auch
sein als auch sein eu-weiten gas krieg
gegen europa und gegen die demokratische
staaten eingeläutet worden sind und auch
wir in der bundesregierung wir hier im
parlament tragen eine verantwortung
dafür dass wir diese angriffe mit der
richtigen antwort beantworten und die
richtige antwort ist eine sichere
saubere und bezahlbare
energieversorgung für mensch und
wirtschaft in deutschland zu erhalten
und da haben wir auch schon vieles
richtige getan und darüber haben wir
heute noch viel zu wenig gesprochen wir
tun so wie wenn wir das letzte halbe
jahr einfach gar nichts gemacht hätten
mit dem wind an land gesetzt und mit dem
wind auf see gesetzt haben wir den
ausbau der erneuerbaren energien
beschleunigt etwas was die letzten
bundesregierung die letzten jahre
verschlafen haben mit dem lg
beschleunigungsgesetz haben wir den
einkauf vom gas diversifiziert so dass
wir uns eben nicht mehr von einem
despoten abhängig machen sondern künftig
unsere energieversorgung auch von
demokratischen staaten beziehen können
wir ändern mit dem
bundesemissionsschutzgesetz
befördern wir dass unsere industrie
schneller umrüsten kann von gas auf
andere brennstoffe und wir werden die
biogasproduktion in deutschland erhöhen
alles kleine schritte in einem großen
reigen von maßnahmen die uns in die
energiesicherheit führen werden
aber trotz
trotz all dieser maßnahmen sehen wir
dass mindestens dieser herbst schwierig
wird wir haben ein stresstest der besagt
sogar dass das von grünen geführte
wirtschaftsministerium feststellt
achtung im frühjahr
2024 können schwierige netzengpässe
können schwierige versorgungssituation
vorstehen das heißt dass wir einen
vorschlag vorliegen haben zwei
kernkraftwerke in der reserve zu halten
die frage die wir uns stellen ist der
stresstest wurde nur bis 2024 gemacht
nur für diesen herbst und winter die
frage ist reichen unsere maßnahmen aus
dass wir auch im winter und im harz
2023 im nächsten jahr energiesicherheit
haben weil das versprechen dieser
bundesregierung kann nicht nur sechs
monate halten es muss mindestens bis ins
jahr 2025 halten da wissen wir nämlich
dass unsere guides unsere maßnahmen
greifen werden
[Applaus]
die kurzfristige verfügbarkeit darüber
wissen wir gar nicht sprechen von
kernkraftwerken ist und das hatten sie
stresst setzt auch gezeigt schwierig ein
kernkraftwerk es eben nicht eine
kaffeemaschine dass man an und ausmachen
kann und gerade am beispiel dieser zweig
haben es vorhin gesehen zeigt sich dass
wir eben nicht nur ganz kurzfristig
denken dürfen die so genannte leckage
ist tatsächlich einfach nur ein
verschleißteil dieses verschleiß teilt
es sicher nutzbar bis dezember 2023 aber
selbst im falle eines reserve betriebs
müssen wir doch gucken dass unsere
kernkraftwerke auf dem technisch
höchstem niveau sind und selbst im falle
eines reservebetrieb müssen wir doch die
sicherheit der kernkraftwerke
gewährleisten und das kann mit
nachrüstmaßnahmen das kann mit
investitionen verbunden sein wenn wir
aber diese sicherheitsprüfung machen
wenn wir die technische überwachung
machen wenn wir sicherstellen können
dass in einem reservebetrieb die
kernkraftwerke funktionsfähig sind wenn
wir geld dafür in die hand den ja warum
in gottes namen nutzen wir sie dann
nicht
und dazu kommt auch noch eine
europäische perspektive wir sind
eingebunden in ein europäischen
energiemarkt und diese europäische
energiemarkt heißt dass wir gas von
anderen ländern beziehen übrigens nicht
nur aus russland sondern beispielsweise
unkonventionelles erdgas aus unserem
osteuropäischen nachbarstaaten wir
beziehen aber auch krampf energie aus
anderen ländern und ich möchte bemerken
dass die energiesituation in all unseren
nachbarstaaten nicht wesentlich besser
ist als in deutschland und aus dem
gedanken der europäischen solidarität
heraus sollten wir auch alles tun um die
energiesicherheit bei uns zu schützen
und die vorhandenen ressourcen zu nutzen
weil das unser beitrag zur europäischen
solidarität klein kann
und versorgungs und
versorgungs und energiesicherheit ist
übrigens nicht nur eine frage der
verfügbarkeit
gerade heute sehen viele
wirtschaftszweige sehen viele menschen
das zwar gas und strom vorhanden ist
aber dass sie es sich schlichtweg nicht
mehr leisten können es reicht nicht aus
wenn wir genügend strom und gas da sind
wir müssen ihn auch bezahlbar heiten
damit er den menschen zur verfügung
stehen kann und
auch in diesem bereich sieht wie wertig
und ewig in der bundesregierung mit den
energieplan diese woche mit der
mehrwertsteuersenkung auf gas und mit
der diskussion in europa wie wir einen
deckel auf die energie preise setzen
haben wir schon maßnahmen umgesetzt und
haben wir weitere maßnahmen in visier um
die bezahlbarkeit der energie versorgung
in deutschland zu gewährleisten
aber vor dem hintergrund dieser
diskussion sehen wir auf dass sie weiter
nutzung der kernenergie eine
preisdämpfende wirkt um vier prozent
laut dieser studie die auch andere
parteien und anderen vier tage vorher
aber je kilowattstunde
wenn aber jede kilowattstunde in dieser
situation hilft dann muss am ende auch
gelten es hilft auch jeder euro den wir
sparen
meine damen und herren
meine damen und herren ich erzähle ihnen
alles und ich erzähle auch mein ampel
kollegen kein geheimnis wenn ich sage na
ja vielleicht sind wir uns noch nicht zu
100% eigentlich in diesem punkt könnte
sein aber wir haben uns zusammengesetzt
in einer ampel weil wir gerade in
krisensituationen sehen dass wir
unterschiedliche meinung
unterschiedliche ideen und
unterschiedliche lösungsansätze
zusammenbringen und bis jetzt haben wir
es am ende immer geschafft eine
vernünftige von der gesamtgesellschaft
getragene lösung zu präsentieren und das
werden wir auch in diesem fall schaffen
in dem rahmen
in dem rat ich habe es gesagt wir
brauchen eine gesamtgesellschaftliche
lösung nehme ich den antrag und nimmt
die fdp fraktion den antrag der
unionsfraktion wohlwollend auf als
inhaltlichen beitrag zur debatte die wir
aktuell in deutschland führen
judith skudelny hat es gesagt
wohlwollend auf eigentlich müsste die
fdp mit der union stimmen aber das geht
natürlich nicht nach
koalitionsarithmetik das ist nicht
üblich und da wird es sicherlich auch
noch die diskussion in der ampel geben
die fdp ist für den weiterbetrieb der
akw ist kurzfristig und dieser konflikt
und muss auf dauer aufgelöst wenn jens
spahn für die union stellte der
fraktionsvorsitzende
minister habeck sie haben wir gestern
lautstark die unterstützung der
opposition auch in dieser krise
eingefordert das passt gut zu dieser
debatte fangen wir noch mal beim
problemen an wir haben ein massives
stromproblem seit monaten wir haben
rekordpreise für unternehmen für die
bürgerinnen und bürger beim strom und
beim gas die sich da schon lange nicht
mehr leisten können und und das darf
übrigens nicht vergessen werden jeden
tag wird in deutschland noch immer gas
verströmt gas das wir eigentlich so
dringend einsparen müssten eine lösung
eine offenkundige lösung ist ein mass
eine massive ausweitung
des angebots geht darum jeder aber auch
wirklich jede form der energieerzeugung
die hier in deutschland möglich ist zu
nutzen das ist problem und lösung da
geht es um die frage wie und gerade
daher minister bieten wir ihnen seit
kriegsbeginn konkrete zusammenarbeit und
unterstützung an allerdings haben sie
viele unserer vorschläge bis heute nicht
aufgegriffen und tun es immer noch nicht
nehmen wir die kohle ist wir haben hier
schon im märz gesagt kohlekraftwerke
hochfahren um gasverstromung
runterzufahren seitdem haben sie dann im
juli irgendwann die gesetze geändert
haben damals gesagt jetzt jedes
kohlekraftwerk am netz schauen wir heute
ende september zwei kohlekraftwerke sind
bisher erst am netz weil sie so hohe
auflagen und hürden gemacht haben dass
sie nicht ans netz kommen schaffen sie
diese auflagen weg bringen sie die
kohlekraftwerke ans netz da haben sie
unsere unterstützung sofort und
unmittelbar
biogas windenergie photovoltaik machen
wir seit märz vorschläge wie die
potenziale die es gibt es geht um
steuerrechtliche vorschriften es geht um
den bio deckel viele regulatorische
maßnahmen bis hin zur frage ob die
windräder nachts laufen können wegen der
geräusche das machen wir seit märz
vorschläge die greifen sie jetzt auch im
september das ist gut aber das allein
reicht eben nicht und das bringt uns zum
kern zur kernkraft drei kernkraftwerke
die in deutschland noch laufen etwa 4
megawatt leistung ddh etwa zehn
millionen haushalte die mit strom
versorgt werden und jetzt ist es ja so
herr blankenburg der vorschlag des
ministers ist ja wir machen die
sicherheitsüberprüfung also sie müssen
sich übrigens die frage beantworten was
ist jetzt mit isar 2 wenn dieser 2 in
die reserve soll wie sie vorgeschlagen
haben muss jetzt eben dort auch
entsprechend das ventil ausgetauscht
werden wird das jetzt mit ihrer
unterstützung passieren da nicht der
betreiber muss das wissen sie wollen die
sicherheitsanforderungen müssen sie
natürlich einhalten haben sie uns
wochenlang erzählt geht nicht sie müssen
das recht ändern haben sie uns woche
lang erzählt geht nicht natürlich müssen
sie für die reserve das recht ändern sie
müssen das personal vorhalten weil sie
im fall der fälle die kernkraftwerke
betreiben können müssen haben sie uns
auch erzählt ginge alles nicht und sie
wollen auch noch geld dann zahlen an die
betreiber jeden tag jede woche jeden
monat dafür dass sie in reserve bleiben
wir haben personal wir zahlen das geld
sicherheitsanforderungen werden
überprüft aber strom soll nicht
produziert wenn das kann man keinem
menschen erklären liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen und deswegen sollten diese
kernkraftwerke
durchlaufen
pragmatismus muss jede politische
festlegung schlagen zitat robert habeck
aus dem märz das stimmt bei diesem
angegangen haben sie unsere
unterstützung dann aber tun sie auch
endlich pragmatisch was offenkundig
nötig ist und erhalten uns für
deutschland und europa die energie die
aus diesen drei kernkraftwerken kommt
übrigens wer soll das eigentlich
ersetzen wodurch frau verwenden sollen
das ersetzt werden sollen dann
gaskraftwerke die wegfallende energie
ersetzen oder wer oder was die
kohlekraftwerke sind mich an netz wenn
diese energie wegfällt werden noch mehr
gas kraftwerke laufen müssen wir würden
noch mehr gas verschroben mitten in der
gaskrise das kann nicht die lösung sein
in dieser krise in der aktuellen
und ein letztes sehr bitten
lautstark die unterstützung für ihre
regierungspolitik die spannende frage
herr minister ist aber welchen teil der
regierung sollen wir denn unterstützen
den finanzminister der jeden tag mit
seiner fraktion längere laufzeiten
fordert die grünen
wirtschaftsminister die gefangenen sind
zwischen partei- logik jürgen trittin
lebenswerk und dem was notwendig ist für
das wohl unseres landes
spd www.rhein blankenburg angemerkt
haben und entschlossen sind
also welchen teil der regierung sollen
wir denn unterstützt übrigens bei der
gasanlage wenn ich das mal sagen darf
das gleiche letzter fällen der gasanlage
die fdp herr miersch vom mast ariane
jackpot rüge der minister selbst stellt
die gasanlage in frage hat zweifel an
ihr beschimpften aber lautstark die
opposition wenn sie seine zweifel
aufgreift das ist auch ein kunst stück
politischer rhetorik das muss man sagen
und anerkennen aber
hilft ihm nicht deswegen zusammenfassend
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen wir sind weiterhin und
jederzeit bereit zur zusammenarbeit wird
es immer gewesen unser
fraktionsvorsitzender hat es letzte
sitzungswoche auch noch mal sehr
deutlich gesagt wir sind vor allem dann
bereit wenn sie tun was nötig ist für
deutschland in dieser krise für mehr
strom angebot für bezahlbare preise für
weniger gasverstromung wir sind vor
allem dann zur zusammenarbeit bereit
wenn sie selbst erst mal wissen was sie
tun wollen in dieser krise und endlich
konkrete vorschläge machen und wenn wir
die zusammenarbeit starten wollen unser
gesetzentwurf ist ein konkretes angebot
stimmen sie zu
jens spahn sich der wirt den
fraktionsvorsitzenden wolfgang kubicki
hat mittlerweile hier
denn aller posten übernommen
nächster redner pflegekassen träger spd
fraktion und bei der unionsfraktion kann
er ist sprecher für umwelt naturschutz
nuklearer sicherheit und
verbraucherschutz kassen
trainers nicht mitbekommen das ist ein
wechsel gegeben hat also grämen sie sich
nicht liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
wir sprechen heute über die verlängerung
von atomkraftwerken verlängerung der
laufzeit und ersparen wir sehen sie
ihnen nach dass sie weil sie in den
letzten jahren einen anderen schwerpunkt
hatten nicht so ganz auf der höhe der
zeit sind was die debatten angeht der
stresstest hat ja gerade ergeben dass
die verlängerung der laufzeit dieser
drei akw es keinen signifikanten beitrag
zur senkung der strompreise bringt also
wenn sie ihn schon verdammt als
ideologische spend werk dann werden sie
doch wenigstens vorher mal einblick in
die ergebnisse
überhaupt ist es schon interessant wie
die konservative seite des hauses mit
den anbieter versuchen der ewiggestrigen
umgeht ich werde sehr genau
beobachtet als die verschiedenen reden
gehalten worden es war irgendwas
zwischen versteinerung und fast
unverhohlen dazu zustimmung wenn sie von
ideologie freiheit sprechen und
pragmatismus
dann gebe ich ihnen recht
aber wie können sie dann alle argumente
die ein
sorgfältig durchgeführte stress-test
gebracht habt vom tisch wischen und wie
können sie dann unverhohlen über
jegliche aktuellen entwicklungen hinweg
die rolle rückwärts ins atomzeitalter
programmieren das ist doch ideologie
meine damen und herren
es gibt meldungen
von sicherheitslecks das beeinflusst
offensichtlich die haltung der union und
die haltung der bayerischen
staatsregierung nur wenig wer ist denn
hier ideologisch unterwegs diejenigen
die sachlich ergebnisse ringen um
lösungen aus dem stresstest den man sich
sorgfältig genau die zeit dafür genommen
hat oder sie die jedes
sicherheitsbedenken einfach mal
übergehen und sagen na ja das war ja
sowieso nicht meldepflichtig
na ja was ist denn passiert in bayern
schauen wir uns doch mal an welche rolle
spielt denn die bayerische atomaufsicht
welche rolle spielt die staatsregierung
und welche rolle spielt der tüv süd in
diesem doch bemerkenswerten vorgang wir
haben erfahren dass preußen elektra in
den letzten tagen wohlgemerkt letzte
woche irgendwann die deutsche
atomaufsicht darüber benachrichtigt hat
dass es eine interne ventile karte gibt
so was die formulierung
natürlich nicht sicherheitsrelevant aber
wenn man länger als den 31.12 den
reaktor betreiben möchte dann muss man
ihn noch im oktober runterfahren also
liebe kolleginnen kollegen ich habe
fragen was ist denn das für ein gebannt
ich bin ja kein ingenieur aber gab es
nicht einen besuch von einem gewissen
ministerpräsidenten markus söder seinem
energieminister hubert aiwanger dem für
die atomaufsicht in bayern zuständigen
umweltminister thorsten glauber und ich
glaube auch die sonnenbrille von herrn
merz dort gesehen zu haben weil eben
genau jenen kein kraftwerk isar 2
wurde denn da nicht über
sicherheitsfragen diskutiert man hat ja
am fürther august eine pressekonferenz
gegeben und es gibt ein schreiben vom
tüv süd der übrigens viele millionen
damit verdient hat dass er die aufsicht
über die bayerischen atomkraftwerke
durchgeführt hat in diesem schreiben des
tüv süd der sehr schnell zu der
auffassung gekommen ist wurde der
weiterbetrieb sogar von sechs
atomkraftwerken
gefördert also was ist denn da los in
bayern was ist denn los kann man denn
diesen herren wirklich vertrauen teil
wenn es um eine hochrisikotechnologie
geht wie die kernenergie
jetzt will die bayerische
staatsregierung nichts davon gewusst
haben wir wurden am montag aus den
medien darüber informiert wer hat denn
die bayerische atomaufsicht und wie geht
man denn mit so einer hochrechnung
hochrisikotechnologie um ich würde ja
gar nicht sagen wenn man keine meldung
erhalten hätte aber wenn man sich vorher
schon hinstellt und sagt wir seien mir
und wir wissen alles besser und wir
lassen die atomkraftwerke einfach sechs
an der zahl weiter laufen dann passt es
doch alles nicht zusammen meine damen
und herren es
bleiben fragen
viele fragen die wir gut beantworten
müssen ob wir diese hochrechnung
hochrisikotechnologie weiter in den
händen dieser herren sehen wollen die
gleichen herren übrigens die in bayern
die energiewende
nicht vorangetrieben haben ich würde
sogar sagen an die wand gefahren haben
ich sage nur 10h regel gibt es immer
noch ich sage nur dass es immer noch die
übertragungsnetze für sie zuständig sind
die werden bei gutem verlauf vielleicht
nach dem kriegsende fertig sein das ist
sie faktisch die realität der
ministerpräsident markus söder stellt
sich hin und sagt wir sind ein führendes
land der energiewende und es
funktioniert nichts denn ein ergebnis
dieses stresstestes ist es ja das
worst-case-szenario besteht darin dass
wir netzschwankungen haben in bayern und
warum haben wir den netzschwankungen
doch weil wir nicht genug kapazitäten
aufgebaut haben um unsere
energieversorgung selber zu sichern
sondern weil diese aus dem norden
deutschlands importieren müssen und
dafür fehlen die übertragung des
netzwerke da schließt sich der kreis und
solche heben uns kluge ratschläge auch
die können wir verzichten übrigens auch
auf die großherzige angebotene der
zusammenarbeit wir wissen was wir davon
zu halten haben wir sprachen mit
kollege träger als nächster gegner das
wort der gelege doch da rainer kraft
deflation
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter herr präsident werde
kollegen so beginnt ein ganz kurzer
realitätscheck schauen mal wie es
ausschaut in deutschland derzeit
leistungsdaten kernkraft vier
gigawattstunden verstromt wird gas für
einige stunden das liefert die
windenergie in so ein loch schon
eineinhalb gigawatt das heißt selbst
wenn sie jedes windrad in deutschland
verdoppeln schaffen sie es noch nicht
einmal die leistung von nur drei
verbliebenen kernkraftwerke in
deutschland zu erreichen das ist ihre
forderung für energiesicherheit das ist
komplett armselig dann liebe
bundesregierung herzliche glückwünsche
zum erwerb von drei kernkraftwerken das
ist wunderbar ab dem ersten jahr wird
die deutsche bundesregierung der größte
deutsche betreiber von kernkraft von
nuklear technischen anlagen seien
gleichzeitig haben sie damit natürlich
fünf kohle und gaskraftwerke in russland
mit übernommen und diese unterstützen
mit ihrer strom- und energielieferung
die waffenschmieden des russischen
militärs das heißt in diesem krieg in
der ukraine unterstützen sie derzeit
beide seiten das ist tiefste heuchelei
und
heucheln ist sowieso das aushängeschild
dieser regierung all das was
funktioniert das wollen sie für grün
luftschlösser in deutschland nicht haben
kurze auswahl kernkraft wollen sie
deutschland nicht haben nehmen sie gerne
aus dem ausland kohle wollen sie in
deutschland nicht haben nehmen sie gern
das im ausland gas aus fracking wollen
sie in deutschland nicht haben nehmen
sie gerne aus dem ausland das co2 freie
kernkraftwerk emsland wollen sie am ende
des jahres schließen dafür sollen dann
schwere betriebene power barges also
schwimmende öl kraftwerk auf den flüssen
norddeutschlands auf den fluss
niedersachsens die versorgungssicherheit
sicherstellen dass liebe regierung das
sind energieerzeugungs methoden aus
entwicklungsländern wie ihre
energiepolitik
eine kluge frau hat einmal gesagt man
kann die realität ignorieren aber man
kann nicht die konsequenzen einer
ignorierten realität ignorieren diese
frau alyssa sie noch während rosenbaum
besseren können dass england wurde
bereits in ihrer kindheit doch die
kommunistische mangelwirtschaft mit der
harten realität konfrontiert und diesen
knallharten aufschlag auf der realität
das erleben sie gerade in ihrer
energiepolitik
folgerichtig und zustimmungswert ist da
der gesetzesentwurf der union enthält
natürlich auch effektiv gesagt nichts
anderes als der entwurf der afg mit
denen wir heute abend final abstimmen
würden und wenn sie da zustimmen könnte
man die prozess beschleunigen denn zeit
ist knapp der herr wird minister hat
schon viel zu viele monate verschenkt
und dass man einziger kritikpunkt league
union zeit ist knapp die betreiber
brauchen für administrative dinge für
personalfragen für routine wartung in
alle sga nächsten tag aber sie brauchen
zeit beschleunigen sie ihren prozess und
wenn sie ein prozess beschleunigen dann
können sie auch die kollegen der fdp
immer zum schwur bringen denn die fdp
selber tut nichts einzelne abgeordnete
kommen her und sagen sie würden hier ein
kernkraftwerk er weiter betreiben aber
von fdp kein antrag kennen gesetzt in
wort und auch der wälder niedersachsen
der will wissen wo denn die fdp
tatsächlich steht auf dem boden
energiepolitische vernunft oder will die
fdp einfach nur die annehmlichkeiten
eines funktionalen ampelkoalition
weiterhin teilhaben das will der welt
niedersachsen wissen zwingen sie ihn
dazu
und bleiben wir noch bei ihren
wirtschaftsminister habe seine
entscheidung nur zwei kernkraftwerke und
nur in reserve zu bringen ist
energiepolitisch falsch aber zumindest
hat diese entscheidung 1 aufgezeigt
nämlich wurde damit damit wurde der
prüfer merk aus dem bmi komplett
vorgeführt wir erinnern uns im märz
diesen jahres hat das bmi in einer nacht
und nebelaktion oder es mein
festgestellt zu haben das von den drei
verbliebenen kernkraftwerken keinerlei
beitrag für die energie und strom für
sicherheit im winter 22 23 wird kommen
können die entwicklung ist und anders
die betreiber widersprochen der tüv hat
widersprochen und der
wirtschaftsminister hat nun auch eine
andere lösung dafür gefunden und da
stellt sich die frage die frage ist dann
sind die experten des bmi einfach nur
unfähig eine fachlich richtige korrekte
einschätzung der situation geben zu
können oder hat das baby eine
vorsätzlich falsche entscheidung uns
mitgeteilt und mit ihnen die eigene
bundesregierung dieses parlament die
bürger in deutschland belogen die frau
ministerin was war es denn nun frau
ministerin
unfähigkeit oder eine vorsätzliche
falschaussage aus ihrem haus das würde
ich gerne wissen aber eigentlich ist das
auch schon egal beide versäumnisse sind
so schwer dass sie erst zurücktreten
sollen wir frau ministerin lemke gehen
sie in den weg von frau
spiegel.de aircraft
als nächstes erhebt das wort frau
bundesministerin steffi lemke für die
bundesregierung
bundes- und steffi lemke von den
bündnisgrünen hat jetzt hier zum antrag
der cdu csu änderung des atomgesetzes
das wort liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
ich bin gerade angesichts dieser debatte
dankbar dass wir in den noch laufenden
atomkraftwerken techniker arbeiter und
ingenieure haben die für die sicherheit
dieser atomkraftwerke garantieren an
jedem tag den die atomkraftwerke laufen
ich glaube dass wir in krisenhaften
zeiten gerade mehr sicherheit brauchen
und nicht mehr risiko und ich glaube
dass diese arbeiter techniker und
ingenieure in den atomkraftwerken schon
so etwas wie ein murmeltier taten als
herr merz und schüler im august dort in
ihren weißen anzügen auftauchten und
sagten sie werden im reaktor gewesen und
sinngemäß hätten festgestellt dass alles
in ordnung ist
das halte das für keinen
verantwortlichen umgang mit der
atomkraft und deshalb sage ich ihnen die
entscheidung zum atomausstieg steht
der 2011 in einem breiten in einem
breiten konsens beschlossene
atomausstieg kommt und ich liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen von der cdu csu
ich verstehe gar nicht warum sie nicht
stolz darauf sind dass dieser
atomausstieg kommen wird
sie haben ihn seinerzeit beschlossen
gemeinsam mit der fdp und das war
verantwortungsvolle politik die sie
damals durchgeführt haben und sie haben
damit einen jahrzehntelangen
gesellschaftlichen konflikt in unserem
land befriedet und deshalb geht es hier
nicht um das lebenswerk von herrn
trittin sondern darum dass frau merkel
als damals zuständige bundeskanzlerin
diesen atomausstieg in unserem land mit
unserer unterstützung umgesetzt hat und
[Applaus]
sie können mit ihrem gesetzentwurf hier
nicht darüber hinwegtäuschen dass es
ihnen jetzt jetzt darum geht diese
entscheidung zurück zu drehen herberger
schauen sie sich ihre rede doch mal an
genau das ist die stelle wo sie ins
stottern gekommen sind als es darum
gehen dass ihr gesetzentwurf nicht nur
bis 20 24 eine laufzeitverlängerung
ermöglichen möchte sondern darüber
hinaus sie wollen das rad der geschichte
der atomkraft in deutschland zurück
drehen und das wird nicht passieren
es ist verantwortungslos wenn sie mit
einer hochrisikotechnologie so umgehen
als wäre es eine kaffeemaschine die sie
ab und zu mal an- und ausschalten können
die sie dann ein bisschen mit wasser neu
befüllen einen neuen filter rein machen
und sie dann wieder anschalten
es hat drei gründe warum wir aus der
atomkraft in deutschland ausgestiegen
sind mit einem gesetzentwurf der cdu
die nutzung ist risikoreich tschernobyl
fukushima und andere katastrophen haben
das gezeigt
zweitens sie ist teuer und sie
produziert hochgiftige
hinterlassenschaften mit denen noch
viele generationen fertig werden müssen
und drittens die sicherheitslage von
atomkraftwerken hat sich im februar
2022 in europa massiv und radikal
geändert sie sind zum tricks ziel des
krieges russlands gegen die ukraine
geworden und dass es wenige hundert
kilometer von hier entfernt
und ich habe mir zumindest nicht
vorstellen können als ich gegen
atomkraft demonstriert habe aus guten
gründen ich habe ihnen die hier gesagt
ich habe mir damals nicht vorstellen
können dass wir über den wiedereinstieg
in die atomkraft auf initiative der cdu
diskutieren während diese kraftwerke
kriegsziele geworden sind wenige hundert
kilometer von uns entfernt
und deshalb
und deshalb sehr geehrte damen und
herren wird es kein wiedereinstieg in
die atomkraft geben wir werden jetzt und
das haben minister habeck und ich
angekündigt sorgfältig prüfen ob für den
kommenden winter zwei der noch drei
laufenden akw es möglicherweise als
reserve gebraucht werden um auf eine
mögliche krisenhafte zuspitzung der
versorgungslage reagieren zu können
gerade das drastische versagen der
atomkraftwerke in frankreich wird diese
entscheidung möglicherweise hier in
deutschland erzwingen
und deshalb ist es richtig eine
bereitschaft reserve vorzuhalten aber
nicht daraus mit billigen populismus die
konsequenz zu ziehen die atomkraft um
mehrere jahre verlängern zu wollen
die verantwortung zu übernehmen heißt
auch transparent und ehrlich zu
kommunizieren und das haben wir in
dieser woche getan nachdem die kenntnis
davon erhalten haben dass es eine
ventile catamarca zwei akw isar 2 gibt
die kein sicherheitsproblem ist das habe
ich direkt gesagt im laufenden betrieb
kein sicherheitsproblem ist aber ein
technisches und jetzt darüber
entschieden werden muss wie wir damit
umgehen es ist ein langer absehbares ist
ein berechenbares es ist ein
mechanisches problem was wird vorliegt
das aber dazu führt dass das akw jetzt
im herbst wo wir auch schon eine
problematische strom situation aufgrund
der fehlenden atomkraftwerke in
frankreich haben vom netz genommen
werden muss und dass diese informationen
von der bayerischen atomaufsicht uns
nicht rechtzeitig mitgeteilt worden ist
ich lasse das hier mal unkommentiert im
raum stehen
hier werden die endspiele werden die
notwendigen antworten auf die
gegenwärtige energie situation geben in
dem der erstens die erneuerbaren radikal
ausbauen werden indem wir zweitens
energieeffizienz und energieeinsparung
vorantreiben werden indem wir in diesem
winter noch einmal auf alte energie
versorgungsform zurückgreifen und dafür
auch den reservebetrieb für drei für
zwei der drei noch laufenden akw s
ermöglichen werden wenn er notwendig ist
vielen dank
steffi lemke am anfang ihrer rede hat
sie gesagt die entscheidung zu
atomausstieg steht der atomausstieg ist
entschieden zum 31 12 dieses jahres
jetzt am schluss hat sich noch mal
ausgeführt sowohl ihr ministerkollege
haben die auch sie ist bereit ein
bereitschafts reserve für zwei
atomkraftwerke über den ersten januar
hinaus laufen zu lassen das dürfte noch
muntere diskussionen geben auf dem
parteitag der bündnisgrünen der im
oktober folgen wird so und jetzt
müsste es in der debatte weiter gehen
nämlich
frau ministerin ich hätte sie gerne
gefragt
bei ihrer bei ihrer rede
zu einem vorgang zu dem ich eine
stellungnahme des bmu vermisse ich habe
angst aber schaut auf twitter ich habe
noch mal geschaut auf den
pressemeldungen ihres hauses das ist
über ein weg plastikgeschirr und über
erben gardening
fassadenbegrünung
und andere biodiversitäts fragen in
jüngsten tagen getwittert worden auch
darüber dass sie unzufrieden sind über
diese meldung eines nicht
meldepflichtigen vorgang ist aus dem
bayerischen kernkraftwerke aber ich sehe
nur dröhnendes schweigen zu der frage
das vor zwei tagen
mit einem beispiellosen sabotageakt in
jänschwalde 200 kilometer verdienen
entfernt hätten sie mehr zuschauen
gehabt durch
kriminelle
landfriedensbruch ein gigawatt
gesicherter leistung vom netz genommen
werden musste weil die dort meinten in
ihrem privatkrieg sich auf gleise
festzukleben an ketten zu müssen und was
weiß ich was alles und aus dem
ministerium dröhnendes schweigen wie aus
der ganzen partei wo ist dein frau
neugebauer die ja ständig in allen
talkshows ist und da auch mal was zu
sagen könnte was sind sie bereit mit uns
zusammen heute der brandenburgischen
landespolizei und innenminister michael
stücken dafür zu danken dass sie diesen
zirkus schnell beendet haben und die
brandenburger justiz auffordern die
straftäter ihrer strafe zuzuführen
[Applaus]
oder so
sehr geehrter herr abgeordnete dort zum
einen ist es natürlich begrüßenswert
dass sie sich die website des bmv
intensiv anschauen und die studieren
zum zweiten werden sie da noch
wesentlich mehr informationen finden als
das was ihr jetzt so ein ganz bisschen
versuchen zuvor ohne bibeln und es tut
mir leid dass offensichtlich in der cdu
die krise des arten aussterben es immer
noch nicht verstanden wurde aber das ist
heute auch nicht unser thema
wenn sie auf dieser website weiter
geschaut hätten wenn sie dann ein
bisschen mehr zeit noch investieren
wollen auch wenn sie auf meinen
twitter-account noch weiter schauen
wollen dann werden sie noch viele andere
informationen finden und das bmf hat
sich unter anderem in den letzten tagen
in den letzten wochen sehr intensiv mit
der frage sicherung der
energieversorgung in unserem land
auseinandergesetzt und dazu gehört die
sehr intensive debatte die das bmw k und
das bsv führen um sicherzustellen dass
wenn es notwendig ist wenn die energie
versorgungs lage es erfordert
sie sind aber gar nicht gefragt ich bin
gefragt glaube ich wenn ich das richtig
verstanden habe und das werden sie mir
überlassen wie ich fragen beantworte
herr abgeordnete dort dann gibt sie
werden dort auch finden dass wir uns
über die frage wie der reservebetrieb
organisiert werden kann wenn er
notwendig ist intensiv ausgetauscht
haben und das bearbeitet haben und sich
deshalb am dienstag am montag die
öffentlichkeit informiert habe über die
probleme er hatte mich auch frau
abgeordnete zur frage der
energiesicherheit haben sie vielleicht
nicht hingehört weil sie zu sehr fixiert
sind auf ihre details befragt und jetzt
zu dem thema das sie im zweiten teil
ihrer frage angesprochen haben ich habe
auch schon mehr fahren wenn sie in
meinen twitter-account zurückgehen
finden sie das deutlich gemacht dass
sich kriminelle proteste dass sich
kriminelle blockaden und dass sich die
frage der gefährdung von sicherheit von
menschen durch solche proteste ablehne
und sie kritisiert habe öffentlich und
klar und deutlich kritisiert habe das
habe ich getan
und ich wäre dankbar wenn sie und ich
vielleicht dennoch einen konsens darüber
herstellen könnten dass eine junge
generation jetzt auf die straße geht und
protestiert sie wird das morgen geht tun
in einem friedlichen und in einem
zivilen protest dass es dafür gründe
gibt weil sich diese jungen menschen
sorge um ihre zukunft machen
bei ihrer partei unter anderem den
ausbau der erneuerbaren energie und den
kampf gegen die klimakrise wintersaaten
aussterben jahre und jahrzehntelang
vernachlässigt hat vielen dank herr
kollege
viel applaus von grünen und spd nicht
richtig verstanden habe dass die
ministerin damit einverstanden dass sich
protestler fest leben und die versorgung
zum beispiel spalte in der zeitung mit
ungefährdet war nun mal so fürs
protokoll die nächste rednerin jetzt
kommt von der cdu/csu anja weisgerber
machiavelli wusste mit wankelmut und
nachgiebigkeit erreicht man gar nichts
der wankelmut von bundesminister habeck
wird vor allem durch die von ihm
vorgeschlagene notreserve für nur zwei
kernkraftwerke deutlich die
einsatzreserve ist eine totale
fehlkonstruktion und auch nicht
praktikabel
wir halten die kernkraftwerke für viel
geld vor und wissen noch gar nicht ob
wir sie dann wirklich nutzen das
verursacht kosten
möglicherweise ohne auch nur eine
kilowattstunde günstigen strom zu
produzieren
das ist ehrlich gesagt lieber herr
minister liebe frau ministerin ein
schlechter witz die anderen länder
europas schütteln doch den kopf über
diese entscheidung der ampel regierung
die menschen in unserem land merken wenn
sie verschaukelt werden und sie merken
auch wenn die regierung einfach nicht
alle optionen nutzt die wir haben auch
der stresstest gesagt das netz engpässe
drohen wenn wir die drei noch am netz
befindlichen
grundlastfähigen kernkraftwerke vom netz
nehmen deshalb legen wir heute einen
ganz konkreten
gesetzentwurf vor mit dem wir die
gesetzlichen rahmenbedingungen dafür
schaffen die kernkraftwerke bis ende
2024 weiterlaufen zu lassen denn das ist
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
neben dem ausbau und ich betone dass
neben dem wichtigen ausbau der
erneuerbaren energie die einzig richtige
entscheidung auch im blick auf die
energieversorgungssicherheit und die
preisentwicklung
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
entscheiden sie endlich nicht nach
parteiprogramm und ideologie sondern
treffen sie endlich eine pragmatische
entscheidung und unterstützen sie
unseren gesetzentwurf erstes signal in
die richtung haben wir ja heute von der
fdp gehört
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen wir
könnten wieder vertrauen in unserem land
zurückgewinnen wenn wir in so einer
krisensituation über parteigrenzen
hinweg zusammen die notwendigen
entscheidungen treffen der gesetzentwurf
bedeutet kein ausstieg aus dem ausstieg
sondern stellt lediglich eine brücke da
gleichzeitig müssen wir den ausbau der
erneuerbaren energien massiv
beschleunigen und da brauchen wir auch
planungs beschleunigung nicht nur mit
blick auf die windenergie wie sie es
vorschlagen und ja ich komme aus bayern
aus franken wie man hört und ich weiß
was jetzt einige von ihnen wieder gleich
zwischenrufen aber sprechen wir doch mal
über die fakten bayern ist spitze bei
der energieerzeugung aus sonne wasser
und biomasse kann hat soviel
grundlastfähige ich wiederhole
grundlastfähige erneuerbare energien die
bayern feiern
produziert mehr energie durch
wasserkraft als rheinland pfalz in summe
an erneuerbaren energien produziert wir
haben in bayern mehr bioenergie als
hessen insgesamt an erneuerbaren
energien produziert und bei der
windkraft liegt bayern allen unkenrufen
zum trotz auf platz 8 was die
installierte leistung angeht klar wir
können immer besser werden aber keiner
keiner von ihnen hat überhaupt
registriert dass wir in dem bereich
nämlich in den vorranggebieten in den
vorranggebieten wo windkraftwerke gebaut
werden ausnahmen von der 10h regelung
gemacht haben wir brauchen alle optionen
jahr wind biomasse aber wir brauchen
eben auch die weitere nutzung der
kernenergie und die aufregung und die
aufregung jetzt zu dem ventil bei isar 2
ist ein reines ablenkungsmanöver
das ist nicht sicherheitsrelevant das
ist ein routinemäßiger vorgang wenn sie
liebe ampel jetzt endlich die notwendige
entscheidungen treffen würden dann
könnten wir die dringend notwendigen
drei kernkraftwerke neben dem ausbau der
erneuerbaren energien weiter laufen
lassen vielen dank
vielen dank frau kollegin
weisgerber
als nächste hält das wort der kollege
helmut kleebank spd fraktion
sehr geehrter herr präsident
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen sehr
geehrte frau dr weiß ja aber wenn sie
eins gerade geschafft haben mit ihrem
vergleich dann haben wir unsere
bayerischen kolleginnen und kollegen
ordentlich auf die palme gebracht denn
ihre zahlen waren ja nicht bezogen auf
quadratmeter sondern auf gesamte
landesfläche und da macht es dann doch
einen ordentlichen unterschied wenn man
mit wem vergleicht abgesehen davon dass
nicht alle vergleiche wahrscheinlich
auch in bayern gut ankommen wie ich
gehört habe
es sind zwei zwei aspekte auf die ich
eingehen will der vorliegende
gesetzentwurf das vorliegende papier ist
nämlich ein sehr fehlt vielen stellen
vollkommen unzureichend sie gehen auf
zahlreiche wesentliche aspekte in keiner
weise ein und das finden sind für mich
einmal die frage hilft es überhaupt
durch den winter zu kommen und der
zweite aspekt ist welche konsequenzen
welche notwendigen folgerungen gibt es
eigentlich aus der von ihnen
vorgeschlagenen zweijährigen
verlängerung und ich will gleich mal
einen punkt ein wenig vertiefen der
schon angeklungen ist aber es lohnt sich
noch moment drüber nachzudenken nämlich
die frage der brennstäbe des
brennstoffes
in ihrem gesamten papier kommt dieser
begriff nicht ein einziges mal vor sie
umschiffen ihm wahrscheinlich wissen sie
dass das sozusagen die achillesferse
ihres vorschlags ist ich weiß jetzt wird
kommt man hätte vor sechs monaten und so
weiter über die lieferzeit ist schon
gesprochen worden zwölf bis fünfzehn
manche sagen es 18 monate es kommt aber
folgendes hinzu und darüber sollten sie
auch noch mal nachdenken in allen akw es
werden die brennstäbe im wechsel
getauscht das heißt brennstoff brennstab
wechsel stehen nicht nur bei sa2 an
sondern auch bei den anderen kraftwerken
das heißt wir vorschlag beinhaltet im
kern die nachbestellung von brennstäben
die dann wieder eine verwendungsdauer
von vier bis acht jahren haben die man
natürlich nicht sozusagen im anschluss
nach zwei jahren einfach entfernt sie
machen sozusagen die hintertür auf für
die unbegrenzte verlängerung der
atomkraft und das lehnen wir ab
habe ich gelesen
auf die fragen der kosten für
steuerzahler gehen sie nicht allen da
kann man sagen das ist ein bisschen in
angesichts der lage
ist das weniger wesentlich das ist
richtig aber sie gehen auf das thema
sicherheitsüberprüfungen einzig
verlängern die frisst alles okay das
kann man so machen aber damit ergibt
sich ein anderer aspekt den sie nicht
bedacht haben nämlich das thema
stillstandszeiten auch die deutschen
kraftwerke haben stillstandszeiten von
rund 30 prozent
das bedeutet auf drei akw
runtergerechnet 1 steht immer still egal
was sie tun 1 wird immer stillstehen
entweder durch reparaturen oder durch
sicherheitsüberprüfung oder durch
unvorhergesehene notfälle also von daher
auch da funktioniert ihr plan nicht
noch zu vertiefen aus dem stresstest der
stresstest ist eine theoretische
untersuchung eine berechnung unter
bestimmten annahmen was passiert wenn
und auch da lohnt es sich noch mal
hinzuschauen
der strom fehlt im wesentlichen im süden
wir sind darauf schon eingegangen ausbau
der netze und erneuerbaren ausbauen die
zahlen von vdr weisgerber ändern daran
überhaupt nichts vielleicht noch einmal
interessant zu wissen im ersten halbjahr
dieses jahres gegen den bundesweit 238
windräder in betrieb raten sie mal wie
viele davon in bayern genau 3 herzlichen
glückwunsch herr söder
der stresstest
sagt dass es ein problem gibt
theoretisch für wenige stunden
ich finde es total spannend dass in
frankreich bis zu 32 akw vom netz
genommen werden mussten von insgesamt
weit über 50 ohne dass wir netz
schwierigkeiten bekommen haben also das
europäische stromnetz funktioniert
offensichtlich gut genau wir haben gas
verstromt und da kommen wir sozusagen zu
dem punkt nein da können wir genau zu
dem punkt denn die allermeisten die
allermeisten gas kraftwerke die strom
erzeugen produzieren gleichzeitig auf
wärme und die können wir im winter gar
nicht abschalten die werden wir auch im
winter gar nicht abschalten weil wir die
fernwärme sicherstellen das heißt ihr
argument damit könnte tatsächlich der
strompreis sinken das zieht nicht durch
die kopplung zieht das nicht und
deswegen ist uns wichtig deswegen ist
richtig dass wir versuchen das zu
entkoppeln
vielleicht nur ganz kurz auch darauf ist
schon eingegangen worden für den
kommenden winter sind die notwendigen
und richtigen maßnahmen aus meiner sicht
absolut in der pipeline die haben die
gasspeicher gefüllt obwohl wir gas strom
auch exportieren zum beispiel nach
frankreich trotzdem ist es gelungen über
90 prozent zu füllen das lng thema ist
schon benannt worden wir haben genau das
was sie auch hier schon angesprochen
habe auf den weg nämlich den booster für
die erneuerbaren energien für die
biogasanlagen für die windkraft auch das
ist schon mal antworten für die
photovoltaik und das alles flankieren
wir auch noch durch drei
entlastungspaket für die bürgerinnen und
bürger
für den nachfolgenden wind dass sie
adressieren denen ja auch wird aus
meiner sicht die situation eine völlig
andere sein weil wir werden mit den lng
lieferungen werden wir dieses strom
thema so nicht mehr haben da bin ich mir
ganz sicher wir haben eine höhere
verfügbarkeit von kohlekraftwerken und
auch wenn der endgültige netzausbau
sicherlich nicht geschafft sein wird so
werden doch einige schnittstellen im
sicherlich noch unvollständigen
europäischen stromnetz geschlossen
werden können das heißt ihre den
übernächsten winter zu adressieren geht
viel zu weit und deswegen ist aus
unserer sicht aus meiner sicht das was
die bundesregierung vor vorhat die
bereithaltung völlig richtig da werden
wir mittel- bis langfristig erkennen
können also einige wochen vorher wie das
wie die wetterlage sich entwickelt wie
die füllstände der flüsse sich
entwickelt wie die füllstände der
kohlelager sich entwickeln wie es in
frankreich weiter geht mit ihren
atomkraftwerken und so werden wir das
tun und deswegen ist ihr antrag leider
keine lösung dankeschön
vielen dank herr
kollege klebern minister reden herr dr
klaus wiener cdu csu fraktion
[Applaus]
ja sehr geehrter herr präsident liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen deutschland
steckt in der schwersten energiekrise
seiner wirtschaftsgeschichte und die
folgen sind massiv ja die menschen
erleben dass die rechnungen dramatisch
ansteigen und dadurch dass es sicher
wird der konsum eingeschränkt werden das
allein spricht für eine tiefe rezession
in deutschland aber auch bei vielen
unternehmen führen die gestiegenen
kosten dazu dass dringend erforderliche
investitionen
schlicht nicht mehr finanzierbar sind
ich spreche beruflich schon seit vielen
jahren mit unternehmen aber noch nie
noch nie waren die wirtschaftlichen
sorgen so groß ja die existenzängste so
groß und die verärgerung weil die ampel
sich hartnäckig weigert wirklich alle
möglichkeiten auszuschöpfen um die krise
zu lindern
um es einmal deutlich zu sagen dieser
dramatischen wirtschaftlichen situation
4,2 gigawatt strom aus dem markt zu
nehmen das muss man sich erstmal trauen
was
was wäre sinnvoll natürlich das mal
vorneweg wir müssen die erneuerbaren
energien ausbauen und zwar massiv aber
dass wir zeit brauchen das müssen sie
doch mal erkennen und das wird geld
kosten viel geld weil material fehlt
auch in windrädern stecken übrigens
seltene erden und weil fachkräfte fehlen
und im übrigen deutschland hat in den
jahren 2005 bis 2020 den anteil der
erneuerbaren energien bereits von 5 auf
20 prozent ausgebaut das ist
überdurchschnittlich nicht nur im
eu-vergleich sondern auch im
oecd-vergleich und sogar im weltweiten
vergleich also von wegen 16 jahre ist
nichts passiert dieses narrativ können
sich mal langsam schon
ist hier allerdings jaja zu wenig wissen
wir allerdings die erneuerbaren
hinreichend ausgebaut haben im sinne
einer echten grundlastfähigkeit müssen
wirklich alle optionen auf den tisch und
dazu gehören eben auch die
kernkraftwerke sind sicher und sie
können ohne weiteres ein paar jahre
weiter laufen und ja das würde einen
unterschied machen zum beispiel beim co2
ausstoß ich glaube die klimaziele gelten
doch noch oder oder auch bei der
preisbildung wer die märkte zumindest
ein bisschen kennt der weiß das ist
manchmal in einer mangel lage nicht viel
braucht um wirklich preisdämpfend zu
wirken bei unsere dringende bitte seien
sie dass sie in dieser schweren krise
einfach mal pragmatisch und nicht
unflexiblen riskant und teuer die frau
verlinken gerade gesagt hat seien sie
zudem ehrlich zu den menschen und legen
sie keine prüfer merkel vor die
innerhalb weniger tage von den experten
zerrissen werden machen sie keine
stresstests
die nur den kleinen ausschnitt eines
streck betriebs beleuchten und
verbreiten sie keine panik in dem sie
eine undichte stelle bei einem ventil
als sicherheitsrelevantes risiko ein
verkaufen das ist lächerlich das ist
lächerlich dass es nicht mehr
meldepflichtig und stellen sich am ende
nicht gegen den raten experten die
listen die netzbetreiber und der
sachverständigenrat schlagen ein
weiterbetrieb vor handeln sie im
interesse der menschen stimmen sie
unserem gesetz denn nur mit einem
verbesserten angebot an energie werden
wir in der lage seid diese krise auch
ohne wirtschaftliche dauerhafte
wirtschaftliche schäden zu meistern
vielen dank der appell von klaus biener
von der cdu/csu aber er weiß natürlich
auch dass
und wohnen in der opposition ist in
dieser antrag sicherlich keine mehrheit
hier heute finden wird harald ebner
jetzt für die bündnisgrünen als letzter
redner in der debatte um die änderung
des atomgesetzes ein antrag der cdu csu
fraktion
präsident werde die kolleginnen und
kollegen kollege wiener in bayern ist
alles anders da stecken die seltenen
erblichen den windkraftanlagen sondern
da stecken die windkraftanlagen selten
in der erde und es ist der große
unterschied
niemand hat die absicht niemand hat die
absicht den eugh atom ausstieg aus dem
atomausstieg auszusteigen die union aber
sehr wohl sie legen uns heute einen
entwurf dame vor mit dem sie ungeniert
den atomausstieg rückabwickeln wollen
und doch das wollen sie tun weil ich sie
erneute prüfungen erneute fortsetzung
der verlängerung in ihrem gesetzentwurf
schon vorsehen das werden wir nicht
mitmachen das sage ich ihnen heute schon
und sie sind ja noch nicht mal sie sind
ja noch nicht mal bereit objektive
fakten außen stresstester netzbetreiber
anzuerkennen und sie übersehen vor allem
eines dass der stresstest eben überhaupt
kein sicherheitstest war unter wunder
wundere ich mich schon mit welcher
nonchalance hier die union sämtliche
fragen der nuklearen sicherheit über
bord wirft sie bauen darauf dass in
diesen tagen die menschen das gar nicht
merken aber sicherheit sicherheit kann
und darf nicht nach tagesform neu
definiert werden sondern nukleares
sicherheitsfragen sind nicht
verhandelbar und
mit ihrem vorschlag mit ihrem vorschlag
die längst überfällige
sicherheitsüberprüfung weiter
aufzuschieben schlagen sie dem fass
endgültig den boden aus ich habe sehr
genau gelesen und es lohnt sie ist kann
ich jedem empfehlen und ihre offene
laufzeitverlängerung die stellt ja nicht
nur die sicherheitsfragen hinten an
sondern die auch fordert auch die
herstellung und den einsatz neuer
brennelemente
und wenn sie jetzt sagen dass es auf die
eine oder andere tonne eine oder andere
tonnen hochradioaktiven atommülls
übrigens heißt nicht kern will sondern
atommüll gar nicht mehr ankommen dann
halte ich das sehr für zynisch und wer
hier noch mehr radioaktiven müll in die
welt setzen will der gefährdet die
ohnehin schwierige endlagersuche in
diesem land mutwillig wir werden das
nicht mitnehmen damit hinnehmen danke
schön
herr kollege
damit schließt sich die aussprache
interfraktionell wird überweisung des
gesetzentwurfs auf drucksache 3488 an
die juristisch es ist natürlich ein
gesetzentwurf ich habe eben am tag
gesagt da muss man sauber bleiben dass
der gesetzentwurf geht jetzt in die
entspricht